Do you have,
don't be evil in the cash him?
No,
no,
no.
You should not.
Maybe just take it so on one of our,
one of our like equivalent operating principles within cash and squares,
like under like how do we understand someone's struggle?
Like,
oh,
how do we understand like how do we have the empathy for like what they're
struggling with?
And like when it comes to finance,
they're struggling with a lot.
Yeah.
Typically they're struggling with a ton.
What was the thought process with,
I mean,
one of the things that's kind of cool about the cash app is that you can buy and
sell bitcoin with it.
Yeah.
Um,
are you go,
are you guys going to consider other forms of cryptocurrency as well?
Not right now.
I,
so back to the Internet.
I believe that Internet will have a native currency.
Really.
It'll have a native currency.
And I don't know if it's Bitcoin,
I think it will be good just given all the tests it's been through and the
principles behind it,
how it was created.
And um,
you know,
it was,
it was something that was born on the Internet that was developed on the
Internet that it was tested on the Internet.
It is of the Internet.
And the reason we,
um,
you know,
we enabled the purchasing of bitcoin within,
within the cash APP is one we want to learn about the technology and we want to
put ourselves out there and take some risk where the first publicly traded
company to actually offer it as a service where the first publicly traded
company to talk to the SCC about bitcoin in what that,
what that means.
And it made us uncomfortable.
We had to,
we had to,
you know,
like really understand what was going on and,
and that was critical and important.
And then the second thing is that we,
you know,
we would,
we would love to see something become a global currency.
I did.
It enables more access.
It,
it allows us to serve more people.
It allows us to move much faster around the world.
And,
um,
we,
uh,
we thought we were going to start with how you can use it transactionally,
but we notice that people were treating it more like an asset,
like a,
like a virtual gold.
And we wanted to,
um,
we want to just to make that easy.
Like I'm just the simplest way to buy and sell bitcoin.
But we also knew that it had to come with a lot of education had to come with
constraint because,
you know,
two years ago people did some really unhealthy things about,
purchasing bitcoin.
They maxed out their credit cards and,
um,
put all their life savings into,
into bitcoins.
So we,
we developed some,
some very simple,
uh,
restrictions and constraints like you can,
you can't buy bitcoin on the cash app with a credit card.
You have to,
it has to be the money you actually have in it.
And we look for day trading,
which we,
uh,
we discourage and shut down like that.
That's not what we were trying to build.
That's not what we are trying to optimize for.
We made a a children's book explaining what Bitcoin is and where it came from
and how people use it and where am I be going.
So we,
we really tried to take on the role of education and,
and,
and have some like very simple healthy constraints that allowed to be allowed
people to consider what their actions are in,
in the space.
Now when you have something like the cash app,
which is a,
it's very much a disruptive technology in terms of like decentralization of,
of banks and,
and,
and currency and you know,
to have it where everything is going right at your direct depositing a paycheck
right in the app if you so choose.
And then you could also buy bitcoin,
which is another disruptive technology mean that this is a,
another step towards this sort of new way of doing things.
Yeah.
And is there pushback from,
from any companies or is there
oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean like you just look at like some of the major banks in their consideration
around bitcoin.
They all love blockchain because of the efficiencies that can create for their
business and potentially new business lines.
But,
um,
you know,
I think there is a explain blockchain to people for people that know what we're
talking about.
Blockchain is a distributed ledger and it,
what that means is that,
um,
it's basically a distributed database where,
you know,
the,
the source of truth can be verified at any point around the network.
And you can see,
you know,
um,
this,
this annotation around how content or how are around money,
like traveled.
Um,
so you don't have to go to an institution.
So the records,
yeah,
there's no centralized check,
there's no centralized control over it.
Um,
and I think that is a threatening,
it's,
it's certainly threatening,
um,
to certain services behind banks and financial institutions.
It's threatening to some governments as well.
Um,
so I just look at this and like how do we embrace this technology,
not react to it in a,
in,
you know,
more from a threat standpoint,
but like what does it enable us to do and where does our value shift?
And that's what we should be talking about right now is like how our value
shifts.
And there's always really strong answers to that question,
but if you're not willing to ask the question in the first place,
you will become irrelevant because technology will just continue to march on and
make you irrelevant.
And it's the people that like are,
are,
you know,
growing up with this technology are born with the technology only knowing that
technology or are asking the tough questions of ourselves that are going to be
super disruptive to their business.
And they're,
they're thinking about right now and they're,
and they're taking actions and you know,
we're doing,
we're doing that at square and we're doing that at Twitter.
And like that to me,
represents longevity.
That represents our ability to,
to thrive.
And we,
we got to push ourselves.
We've got to make ourselves uncomfortable and we got to disrupt what we held
sacred and,
and what we think is success at it.
Because otherwise it's not going be bigger than what we have today.